[Music]
i just feel like
i don't know maybe it's the news i watch
and what i'm reading online all of it
but everything from interest rates
housing markets
inflation like i just like there's so
much heightened
almost anxiety just around money and the
uncertainty and even like russia and
ukraine like the whole thing right like
people are like nervous about that and
that inflation is going to skyrocket if
russia like
there's just a lot of
um anxiety i feel like there's a lot of
negative news about the economy and
about the state of affairs when it comes
to finance yeah and and so yeah there
should be so how do you incur like
what's your there should be some anxiety
around that because you see inflation
continuing to rise and like all that
like well i don't i don't see inflation
continuing to rise like it has been
because this is a different kind of
inflation than the jimmy carter era yeah
on the 70s and the early 80s but even if
russia anything with like i don't know
any other global i don't think that's
going to change our lives you know 20
years from today yeah but um be shocked
if it does but the uh but all the
uncertainty that's in the air
and the pressures on the market
are all it's kind of a perfect storm
there's a whole bunch of bad stuff
happening right at this moment
um
and it's all kind of camouflaged or
covered over by the fact that people are
making more money yes because there's
this shoot up in incomes
and and there's a shoot up in personal
debt credit card debts the highest
credit card debt on uh since like 2007
this year in 2021 it's out of control
spending people are spending their
brains out out there and so what these
kinds of economic indicators end up
doing is we end up having some kind of
problem with their overall the economy
that does affect your life unless you're
the third pig
and so the way you handle the anxiety of
the negative news about
that
you know not not taking any of it to the
extreme where you think that oh the
world's coming to an end because it's
not
not on any of these issues but uh but
but you do know okay i'm concerned i'm
not freaked out i'm concerned well
concern's good because that makes you
get ready for the storm i'm afraid
there's a storm coming yeah i don't
really think i'm gonna hit both a
tornado but i'm gonna prepare and act
like
you know we're gonna act like we're
gonna act like you know that we're gonna
have some good sense we're not gonna
stand out in the yard and look for it
right and so uh the third pig means
that's the third pig and the three
little pigs that built a brick house and
that means you get out of debt you have
an emergency fund you have a budget you
start to build some wealth when you
don't have any debt you have a pile of
money and bad things happen in the
economy it doesn't affect you yep nearly
as bad as if you have no money and
you're deeply in debt
it destabilizes everything so i i never
want to call have fear be the motivator
i want hope to be the motivator but if
you are feeling anxious and a lot of
people are
about some of the economic indicators
let that be your motivation to get your
crap together oh my gosh yep this is
your call hello you know i mean that's
really what it is yeah well and giving
and that gives people a sense
that you can control what you can
control right like what's going on in
your house those are variables you can
control yes it's focusing on that and
all this other stuff that you just can't
you can't if you think the republicans
are going to save your life you're wrong
and if you think the democrats are going
to save your life you're really wrong i
mean it's just not going to happen
you know
i've been doing this i'm old and i've
never gotten anything out of washington
except trouble yeah you know i mean it's
just trouble they don't bring anything
good to me so and that's not just being
anti-government or something it's just
it's called personal responsibility i'm
an adult and i'm responsible for my
future joe biden thank god is not
responsible for my future or a
republican president trump thank god is
not responsible for my future if i
thought either one of them were in
charge of my future i would just be
going i would really have anxiety then
but thank god i know they're not so i
can control the controllables in my life
i can keep my job i can use that money
to build my 401k i can get out of debt
have the emergency fund stay out of debt
i do not have to participate in panic
purchases
oh god it's going up i gotta buy six of
them oh geez man come on
just extra cases of water just in case
y2k some of y'all are still sitting on
that eight gallons of peanut butter from
y2k
and some of you don't even know what
that is cause you weren't born
yet no
oh my gosh but anyway not in the booth
the people in the booth all do know but
hey you got to be 22 years old or older
are you don't that's what we are you are
not born that's weird that's true that's
weird yeah
i usually feel young i'm like the
youthful one here on this show
everything so everything's a matter of
comparison all these terms i'm usually
like i'm the one that's kind of out but
i
actually now feel old yeah but y2k is
yeah how old were you in 2000 in 2000's
i was 12. yeah okay when the world
almost came to an end and y'all had a
new year's eve party that year we had a
great one
we served water
what no everybody was stockpiling water
and you didn't drink bourbon back the
grid was going to be a the grid was
going to be off the line we were going
to lose everything we're you know all
your bank accounts are going to be
frozen yeah you did probably hold your
breath for a little bit when it was like
three two one
what's gonna happen and then everything
all the lights stayed on and we went
right here we are america 22 years later
cheers this is the ramsey show